and then all of a sudden Insurrection
became a bad thing that we weren't
supposed to be in favor of and weren't
supposed to tolerate and we're supposed
to be very against meanwhile just a few
months ago on May 29th of 2021 left-wing
radicals surrounded the White House
broke down the barrier forced the
president of the United States and his
family into the presidential bunker in
the entire media laughed about it and
said it was so mean that Donald Trump
cleared those protesters out of there
before they tried to burn down St John's
well you're forgetting the most
important verse in uh the modern
religion which is uh it's okay when we
do it progressives 23-16. yeah that's
right that's exactly right you don't
understand yes
because we are on a moral High Ground
right so when we say these people are
writing because they're unheard we are
correct and when we're saying you guys
are riding because you're evil and the
devil we are also right there's no
arguing there because there's no
consistent logic there's no consistent
application of values yeah